c'était une vache vais ce sera une
vacherie très cruel alors giflé un an
c'est cruel mais je crois que ça nous
fait rire ce serait bien sûr la justice
sociale d'égalité mais aussi peut-être
un monde où qui aurait été vidée de tous
les gens trop vilain trop laid trop gros
c'est un esthète dictatorial voilà
sûrement l'auto centrisme pas forcément
l'égocentrisme qui est plus il n'y a pas
de vanité forcément mais c'est vrai
qu'il parle beaucoup il s'intéresse
beaucoup à lui y compris ses défauts des
médias de quoi bon alors il est beaucoup
fait référence à jaurès à hugo ce serait
peut-être un personnage historique -
monumental quelqu'un qui aurait comme ça
a épousé l'histoire façon peut-être plus
discrète mais avec deux trois conditions
quasi obsessionnelle le choix qu'il aima
que je dise un chat parce qu'ils on aime
la grâce et une certaine forme de
féminité
mais ce serait finalement un gros un
gros chien genre je mords quand on
m'emmerde
ce serait son enduro qui lui revient de
son enfance algérienne nardine baba quel
club est en général y regarde avec un
air un peu frileux comme ça il fait
ensemble